michael kopeck has been brilliant
whether it's in a starting rotation or
out of the bullpen he's been great
this is third start he's 2-0 the era of
161.
35 strikeouts and 22 and a third that's
about as good as it gets left-handers
have had no shot
right-handers haven't done much better
no snippet there strike three santana
torched by kopec good movement as
michael stays upstairs with the fastball
you see how it darts away from santana
right at the end at 97.
good backspin that is what a high spin
fastball will get you
struck him out fastball to the top
two strikeouts in the inning for kopech
jacob junis will make his fifth start
of the year he's pitching in his 11th
game he's done
a little bit of everything
and it's leveled to left center field it
is one hop
over the wall to become a ground rules
double
souvenir i think euan felt that ball was
going to go out of the ballpark but
unfortunately
to left field the win knocks it down
now he knows he got a good piece of this
so he decides to take a look
[Applause]
premature exhilaration you would say and
it one hops out of the air
yes he did paul southpaw has a card for
everything evidently he's a man for all
seasons
jumping back and it's a call third
strike
i'm not sure if that was in the box but
it certainly had mercedes looking away
and it caught the inside edge
maybe and judas has a scoreless first
back to the fastball popped up third
base side monkatta into foul territory
oh goodness look out laurie garcia
mokada's got it he throws it back in
and collisions just don't need to happen
any more than they already are happening
no and they seem to happen with you on
monkatta consistently that is the play
for a left fielder but
somebody's got a call somebody's got to
take charge and when they do
you have to back off this team can
afford to lose anybody else at this
point and yet
they're still playing bumper cars
to first andrew vaughan dives on it
kopeck gets over
and got the out beautiful play by andrew
vaughn
sprawling out wide of first for out
number two dyson believes he was safe at
first base he believes that kopeck
missed the bag
larry van over made the call dyson wants
to take a look at it but they're telling
dyson to come and sit down and take a
look at it from the bench
we'll watch it again as michael
searching for the bag misses it there
but what he does is get it with his left
foot which is not actually the way you
want to get it
dyson only saw the right foot that's why
he thought he was safe great play by
vaughn he looks at second
can't get it there and michael got it
with his left foot
so here is adam eaton
adam eaton opens up down the right field
line and this ball
is off the top of the fence
adam blows bubbles as he coasts into
second base
and he rips one that nearly got out of
the ballpark
they're checking we'll watch it again
we'll slow it down for you
it's got to cross the yellow line let's
see where this ball hits
it's the top of the yellow line that is
not a home run this is not a home run
it is however a double which is good i
mean that just missed
so lead double here's vaughn
that's a fast ball that's annihilated
bring him home two nothing
[Applause]
tried to sneak that one by him
and he said two home runs and neither of
them were cheapies
folks you're looking ahead at the future
of this guy and you gotta be smiling
because he's gonna hit
and he's gonna hit a lot nine driven in
and that was into the teeth of the wind
that was a blast
oh zach collins rips one up the alley
and right center field
extra bases for the second time in the
double header for zachary
and the sox are cooking here in the
second inning
three and two outside nice work by danny
mendez gets ball four
runners take off there's a ball pulled
and it's in and out of the glove of the
third baseman on a liner alberto
everybody's safe
i have no idea how alberto did not make
the catch that ball was lined
right to his mitt it popped out
[Applause]
and everybody is safe base is loaded
3-1 from brent
[Music]
control issues galore for brent this
season
and there with the base is loaded and
the sox will absolutely take it it's
three nothing
now they're looking for more that'll be
santana
[Applause]
santana gets on a fastball at 97
and he puts the royals on the board so
carlos santana
he went 10 games without an rbi and now
he has an rbi
in three straight games and it really
felt like the royals needed to answer
somehow after the white sox three run
second
and they get one back with two outs
solo they'll take it but this is a short
compact right to the ball
great slider spinning outside and the
third strikeout for kopeck
this was a dandy of a slider and it
doesn't hurt that you have a guy that
literally if it stays in the park
he's gonna be swinging
strike three breaking ball o'hearn is
sent away
we'll watch it again i mean this is
right there
perfect pitch had the whole zone
and nick just frozen
[Applause]
dyson goodbye three strikeouts in the
inning for kopecks
as the white sox do change pitchers here
to start things off in the fifth inning
it is
cody hoyer that has been brought on
there's the change up for cody hoyer
he's used it
more but still not a ton this year and
that was dazzling
well if this comes to him he's going to
be really tough to deal with because he
throws so hard and then you see this
boy you're trying to put away a tough
hitter he does
swing and a miss on a changeup to get
out of the inning so the other guys the
bullpen getting a chance now including
greg holland who's pitcher number five
and
greg holland high set 2-2 swing and a
miss and he strikes out
the rookie vaughn one out one-two pitch
and a swing and a miss he struck him out
with a pitch down
back-to-back strikeouts for greg holland
as he gets vaughn and now
collins 2-2 and a swing and a miss and a
slider in he strikes that billy hamilton
three straight strikeouts after the
lead-off walk
liam hendricks will try to save it
3-1 7th inning 3-1
[Applause]
in the air left-center hamilton puts
away a split for the sox
liam hendricks closes the deal
and the sox do it for the kids tonight
3-1 your final score